21 year
old suspected Pentagon
leaker, Jack Teixeira
was back in court
to waive his right
to a preliminary hearing.
Meanwhile, inside the Pentagon,
the Air Force unit
where he was assigned
has now been stripped
of the intelligence duties
it had as an internal probe ramps up.
A short time
from now, all members of the House
and Senate will be briefed
on the extent of the classified leak.
And it reportedly has yielded
another alarming detail about China.
According to The Washington
Post, one Pentagon
assessment shows
Beijing is about to unveil
a high tech spy drone unit.
Have a look at that right there.
That would give it surveillance program
potentially a significant boost
CNN's Oren Liebermann,
he's at the Pentagon organ.
Oren, as we know,
the Pentagon
still trying to come to terms
with the extent of this on a whole host
of national security threats.
Tell us what specifically we're learning
about this spy drone.
Jim, we have seen
this supersonic spy drone before.
And the image we just saw right
there, the double U.S.
spy drone
that picture from back in 2019
when China showed it off at a parade.
But at the time, it wasn't
believed to be operational.
It was a sort of prototype or a mockup.
But according to The Washington Post
in these leaked documents
we're seeing come
from the Pentagon documents
that CNN has not been able
to obtain or verified.
That program has come a long way
There's WS eight surveillance spy drone,
part of what the U.S.
believes is
part of a Chinese surveillance drone unit
that's based inland from Shanghai.
Take a look at the capable cities
of this drone.
It travels
it mock three plus
or more than three times
the speed of sound
at an altitude of 100,000 feet so far
higher than commercial aircraft.
And because of that, because of its speed
and its altitude,
it's difficult to detect or to intercept.
Making it another potential addition
to what we've seen in terms of China's
spy capabilities.
And of course,
nobody here
forgets the Chinese spy balloon
that traveled over
much of the United States.
What's interesting here is the U.S.
has seen this
in a bit of a role reversal, if you will.
The US had its own
super supersonic spy drone
back in the sixties that called the D.
21.
It was specifically to spy over China
it conducted four unsuccessful missions
back in the late sixties, early seventies
timeframe before that program
was canceled.
Jim, it looks like the Chinese
have very different intentions
and much broader intentions,
which would allow them to spy
on, for example, Taiwan
and parts of South Korea.
Yeah, frankly,
those two planes look a lot
alike, interestingly.
All right.
The fact that the sheriff's unit
now has been removed,
at least temporarily,
from its intelligence duties.
Is that a standard step
when the Pentagon's
doing a damage assessment
here, in effect,
to have that unit removed,
or does it signal
that this is worse than we knew?
Well, it
certainly signals that the Air Force
is taking this very seriously.
Secretary of the Air Force,
Frank Kendall,
removing the 102nd intelligence wing's
mission from them.
They will no longer
at least temporarily collect
and put together data
for combatant commanders
and other senior leaders.
Other wings will do that
as the Air Force investigates
other steps the Air Force is taking.
Take a look at this list
within the next 30 days.
All of the Air Force will do a stand down
or essentially a review
of security procedures
and how to handle classified documents.
They'll also reassess
security procedures
around classified documents
in the handling of sensitive information.
Finally, everyone who has access to
this will be validated
for their need to know basis. Jim.
Oren Liebermann
good to have you at the Pentagon.
As I mentioned a short time ago,
every member of Congress
will be briefed on the Pentagon
leak this afternoon.
CNN's Manu Raju is on Capitol Hill.
Manu, of course,
So this is not the committee
that is cleared
for this level of intelligence,
a bit broader,
probably a bit more of a general
briefing on the extent.
But but what are you
hearing from lawmakers
in advance of this briefing?
Well, there is a lot of concern,
and they do
want to learn more information
from senior administration officials
led by the director
of National Intelligence, Avril Haines,
who will be in the Senate this afternoon
and then in the House
with a number of other
national security officials
detailing the extent of this leak
and how exactly a 21 year old
air national airman
from the Massachusetts
Air National Guard
had access to classified information.
And in talking to
senior members
in both parties,
there is ample concern
about how he got this information
and what Congress should do
to prevent this from happening again.
To me, the
classification of the documents
ought to be reserved
for the very most
exceptional national security risks,
and not
as broadly as it is now,
but as we've seen
with classified materials.
Being at President Trump's
home to President Pence's
office and at President Biden's residence
there, people are not taking care
of classified materials
the way they should
And how in the heck with there
not some system in place
that said,
if this guy was copying
this many documents
why wasn't there a lot going on,
especially with
the security classification?
And that second senator there was Senator
Mark Warner, who chairs the Senate
Intelligence Committee,
who also indicated
that he is still pushing
to get all the access
to the classified records
that were at the homes of Joe
Biden and Donald Trump and Mike Pence.
He's expecting
another tranche of documents
as soon as today as Congress
grapples with this issue.
Why all these classified documents
appear to be leaking,
appear to be in the wrong places,
including this major leak that happened
and deciding what they need to do next.
And Senator Warner asked
such a key question there,
which is why no tracking of this,
because the guy was printing it,
print it out and then sharing it.
Manu Raju on the Hill.
Thanks so much, Boris.
Yeah,
one of many unanswered questions
at this point, Jim.
Let's dig deeper
now on the case against Jack to share
with Bradley Moss.
He's an attorney
who specializes in litigation
related to national security
and security clearance law.
He's also a law partner
at the offices of Mark
Zaid, Bradley,
thank you so much for taking time
to chat with us today.
So there was a delay,
the defense asking for the trial
to be set back about two weeks.
The prosecution supporting that decision.
Did that surprise you?
Not really.
You know, look,
there's only so much to do right now
at the beginning for this.
This would've
been a very preliminary hearing.
If anything,
we've been talking about bail,
which I don't see happening.
He has got a public defender.
What they are most likely doing.
Given the evidence we've seen both
in the indictment
and the media reporting,
they're likely talking about a plea deal
they're trying to see
if there's a viable path
to negotiate something
by which this guy gets maybe
ten to 12 years in prison, outlines
the entirety of what he did
to the government
from a intelligence standpoint,
can make sure to close up
any gaps in its systems
and that he can go forward with his life
once he gets out,
because it's
hard to imagine
what a defense might look like. Right.
Because the evidence there,
there's a clear trail back to him.
Yes.
The evidence mean
the defense is simply going
to be poking holes
in the government's case
if this went to trial,
because it would be the government's
burden, obviously,
to demonstrate beyond a reasonable doubt
that he had,
in fact, done this,
that he had the access,
that he took the documents
that he posted it on this court.
They likely could do so,
but it would be
a little complicated for them
because there'd be issues of classified
access.
There's classified as a statute
called the classified information
Procedures Act
that would come into play,
any number of complicating factors.
So if the government
can play this out with him
and they get what they need
from purposes of a punishment standpoint,
they'll be happy with that.
Now, National Security
Council spokesperson
John Kirby was here in CNN News
Central yesterday,
and he spoke with my colleague,
Jim Sciutto.
He acknowledged
that some of the classified documents
appear to have been
manipulated
and that some of them had information
that was false.
Could that lessen
the severity of the charges
that to share his facing?
It won't lessen the severity,
but it's a reason for him
to look into a plea deal,
because if he can
then debrief the government
on all the documents he knows he took.
And they can start to track down
which ones were authentic
that are out there
that are being viewed all over the media
and which ones were manipulated.
They can clarify for their own
damage assessment
what actually got leaked out.
Where did we have holes
in our security protocols?
And what is the extent of the damage
to US national security?
I'm curious about something
that Oren talked about, and that is that
his unit
was essentially stripped
of its intelligence mission.
Does that imply to you
that other people may be facing
potential charges,
perhaps supervisors in an oversight role
that kind of let them get away with this?
Well, I think at a minimum,
that was a required,
you know, short term thing.
You had this massive breach,
huge breakdown of security protocols.
They had to stop at every there
everything there
to start doing an initial review,
whether or not security messed up,
why he was able to hand transcribe
some of this stuff. And no one noticed.
That's at a minimum
going to possibly result
in personnel actions.
I don't necessarily know
about criminal charges,
but they've got to do a review for that.
Yeah.
A story we will continue to watch.
Bradley, thank you so much for sharing
your story any time.